hi
my name is nick o'leary i'm an open
source developer at ibm
and the project lead of node red in this
talk
i'm going to cover low code development
and why it's interesting for javascript
and node developers
alike i'm going to use node-red as an
example of a loco development tool
and show how it can be easily extended
by adding new nodes to its palette of
capabilities
i'll also talk about what lessons
developing modules for a low code
development
environment can be applied when creating
regular node.js modules
so to start let's talk about low code
development to help put it into context
let's just step back
and think about how coding has evolved
in the beginning
there was machine code the raw binary
used by the computer to control its
circuits
as a developer you had to speak the
computer's native language the second
generation of languages were assembly
languages
these were the first steps towards
accommodating a programmer's needs
rather than those of the computer we
then have a third generation languages
which is what many of us think of when
we talk about programming languages
today
c java python javascript and so on
they are much more independent of the
machine they run on
they are far more portable some more
than others
they provide structured data types
rather than simple bits and bytes
they provide easier ways to organize and
structure code
and then we come to fourth generation of
languages
they tend to be more domain specific
tools with much less of a focus on bits
and bytes
and more interested in the higher level
data they work with
and the key thing to recognize is the
increased layer of abstraction as you go
through these generations of language
each abstraction moves you away from
having to understand the machine code
from having to deal with low-level
memory management from having to decide
how best to represent your data
in whatever binary format
as developers we accept those
abstractions for what they are
they're a convenience to make us more
productive and those abstractions do
more than just that
a modern compiler can generate machine
code that's highly optimized
probably far more so than if you try to
write it by hand
because they can fold in the decades of
experience and knowledge that exists
low code programming is a style of
fourth generation programming language
it typically involves some sort of
graphically driven development
where the developers assembling and
configuring components
rather than hand coding discrete parts
of an application
their graphical nature provides that
increased abstraction
over screens full of code
now before getting too deep i want to
briefly mention the other type of
programming that often gets bundled
together with
low code programming and that's no code
programming
now there's an important distinction no
code programming means
just that the user who may well not
consider themselves a developer in the
slightest
does not need to touch anything that
looks remotely like code
a great example that many of you would
be familiar with
is if this than that as a web service it
allows you to create workflows in your
browser purely through clicking options
whilst it's very versatile it does keep
you somewhat constrained
to the types of integrations they
support and there's nothing wrong with
that
except when you want to do that extra
little thing that's slightly off the
rails that they keep you on
low code by contrast still allows the
user to create workflows through visual
tools
but it does give the user some more
leeway to insert bits of code when it's
needed
different loco tools provide different
degrees of flexibility in that regard
the higher level of abstraction also
helps to make it more accessible
to a wider range of users by hiding the
individual lines of code
a user is able to focus on solving
whatever problem they're trying to
address
they can also be tailored to particular
problem domains
so they're presented in terms of domain
expert who may not be a developer
is able to relate more closely to and
making it easier for a wider range of
users to be able to create applications
is a good thing
but how does this relate to node.js and
javascript
well with node you see a similar pattern
of abstraction
node core provides a set of standard
libraries to provide an abstraction over
the v8 engine
you have things like the http module but
more often than not
you'll use a module that wraps the
low-level http api into something more
consumable
axios got or whichever is the flavor of
the month
these modules don't stop you as a
developer from using the lower level
apis
but it's often more comfortable to use
the higher level
and abstractions goes in the other
direction as well for those tasks that
need the performance of native code
you could choose to create a compiled
add-on and integrate it
relatively seamlessly with your
javascript code
so that now brings us to node-red a
low-code development tool built on top
of node.js
if you haven't seen node-red before this
is what it looks like
you get a browser-based editor with a
palette of nodes down the left hand side
and a workspace in the middle where you
drag on the nodes to create your flows
each node represents a discrete piece of
functionality and it acts as a black box
it receives a message does something
with that message and then passes it on
to whatever other nodes it's wired to
so in this environment you're drawing
the logical flow of information
here i have a flow that defines an http
endpoint when the http request arrives
at node-red
this node is triggered the message it
passes on
contains information about the incoming
request
we pass that to a template node that
generates html content using the data
provided
and then passes it to a response node to
respond to the request
and we can also add in debug nodes to
examine the messages passing through a
flow
so when i now load this url in my
browser you get an html page
and in the node-red editor we see the
message in the debug sidebar
and that's what node-red's about
building applications by drawing the
logical flow of events
the nodes representing each step the
event or message
passes through now node-red comes with
30 or so core nodes
covering a wide set of basic building
blocks nodes to handle setting message
properties
branching the flow based on logic
handling http tcp udp
connections splitting and joining
messages all sorts of things
and as a platform the main way its
capabilities can be extended is by
adding extra nodes to this palette
as it stands there are over two and a
half thousand contributed nodes
available
covering a huge range of topics such as
talking to hardware devices
databases web apis other pieces of
pre-canned logic and so on
and there's always room for more so
let's talk a bit about
what a node actually is under the covers
a node's implemented in two parts a
node.js module that provides its runtime
functionality
defining what the node actually does in
a flow and it has an html file that's
used by the editor to define its
appearance
help text and its edit dialog
those two files are then packaged as a
regular node module
by adding a package.json file that
contains a custom node-red section
that identifies the files in the module
containing nodes
let's dive into a node's code to see how
it's structured
a node's module has to export a single
function
this function is called when the module
is being loaded into the node red
runtime
it gets passed in an object that's the
node's handle into the runtime api
next the code defines a constructor
function for a node
this gets called whenever the runtime
needs to create a new instance of that
node
that happens whenever the users made
some changes in the editor
they click the deploy button the editor
packages up the configuration in a json
format and sends it back to the runtime
the runtime then loops through all the
nodes in the flow configuration
and creates instances of each one
passing in the configuration for that
particular instance
so within the constructor function the
first thing it has to do is call this
utility function
called create node that turns this
object into a proper node-red node
it can then do whatever work it needs to
to get ready to start handling messages
for example it needs to validate its
configuration
maybe it needs to establish a connection
to a remote system
whatever it needs to do so at this point
we've defined the code for creating the
node
next we need to define how the node will
handle messages the runtime passes it
this is done by adding a handler for the
input event
the event is triggered whenever there's
a message for the node
an important point to know here is the
events are handed completely
asynchronously to when they're emitted
which is unlike the core
node event emitter object which is fully
synchronous
the event handler is passed the message
being received
a send function and a done function
the handler can do whatever work it
needs to in response to that message
if it wants to send a message on within
the flow it can pass the new message to
the send function
once it's finished its work for that
message it calls the done
function now this send done pair of
functions were new additions in node
reds 1.0 released late last year
before that nodes would use the node
object's own send function
the reason for using the passed in
function though is it allows the runtime
to correlate the call to send
with the message that was received
allowing for better traceability of your
flows
something we need to make easier to do
within the project generally
now finally the node may also register a
handler for the close event
this gets called when the node is being
stopped by the runtime either because a
new set of flows are being deployed
or the runtime itself is being stopped
this allows the node to clean up any
internal state such as
its database connections or whatever
resources it's created
and that's largely it in terms of the
framework for creating a node
there are a bunch of other apis for
logging errors updating node status and
other features
that we don't need to get into for this
talk
so once we've created this constructor
function the very final thing
is to register it with the runtime using
this call to register type
switching to the html side of the node
there are three things
html content for the node's edit dialog
help text and the javascript code
used to register the node with the
editor which defines various aspects of
its appearance
and lists out the properties of the node
that can be configured by the user
the definition also includes optional
javascript functions that will be run
when the edit dialog for node is being
opened or closed
this allows the edit dialog to provide a
much richer user experience than just a
plain html form
the editor bundles jquery but doesn't
otherwise use any javascript toolkit for
its ui generation
we occasionally get asked about angular
react or one of the other various
javascript frameworks
but we've generally tried not to tie
ourselves to one framework or another
the editor does provide a number of
useful widgets that nodes can use to
build their uis
such as the typed input which allows the
user to specify the type of a property
as well as its value
this makes for a much more consistent
user experience rather than having each
node create its own way to do it
so given the time available today i'm
not going to delve any deeper into how
to create nodes
instead i wanted to talk a bit more
about the general design principles that
apply when creating them
when designing a node for node-red the
first thing to consider is who the
audience is
who are the people that will install the
module add it to the palette and drag it
into their workspace
with low code platforms like node-red
you have to remember the users come from
a much
broader range of experience they may
already be deeply familiar with whatever
functionality your node provides
or they may have no knowledge of the
underlying details
and just know they need that
functionality and the node provides
they may have a very detailed set of
requirements for the node or they may
just want it to work and not worry about
those details
so here are some principles to apply
when designing a node
the first is making it intuitive
a node's configuration is stored as a
set of json key value pairs
exposing that as a plain list of text
boxes and labels assumes the user will
know what is expected in each box for a
simple node that expects perhaps just a
url
username and password that may well be
good enough but when there starts to be
lots of
other options a different approach might
be needed
one of the approaches we took with the
core trigger node for example
was to build the ui in such a way that
the user could
read how it was configured almost as an
english sentence
send hello then wait for five seconds
then send
goodbye it is an approach that would
work in all cases
but it certainly helped in this case
every feature and option you add to the
node increases the cognitive burden
of using the node for feature-rich nodes
it can be quite hard to design their ui
to write all of those features
without also making it much harder to
find a particular
option a user needs to use providing a
user with a clear hierarchy of choice
can also help them reach their desired
configuration
by that i mean only presenting options
that are relevant to the choices a user
has made up to that point
there's certainly a balance to be made
here having options appear and disappear
if overdone
could also be confusing to the user the
key is finding that right balance
the next principle is about having
sensible defaults and this very much
follows on from the
making the node intuitive to use it
should come with a sensible set of
default configuration values
don't force the user to have to set
everything they the first time they want
to use the node
a good example of this is the split node
this node can be used to turn a single
message into a stream of multiple
messages
by default if you give it a string
payload you'll send a message for each
line of text in that string
if you give it an array it sends a
message for each element of the array
and if you give it an object
it will send a message for each key
value pair you don't have to configure
it to do any of that
but if you do want to change its
behavior you can very easily do so
within the node
its partner node the join node will by
default
attempt to join a stream of messages
back together into a single message
essentially reversing whatever the split
node did
but again you can easily give the join
node a manual configuration
if you want it to do something different
the third principle is about choosing
what can be controlled dynamically
nodes expose two different api surfaces
to the user
the configuration properties set in the
edit dialog and the properties of the
individual messages passed to the node
both are means to control the node's
behavior but that doesn't mean
everything should be exposed in both
ways
the http request node allows you to set
the url
of the request in the node itself that's
useful if you're sending the request to
a fixed endpoint where the url never
changes
but the node also allows you to pass in
message.url
to set the url on a per message basis
the node also lets you set custom hp
headers for the request
by setting message.headers but that's an
example of an option that's not exposed
in the node's edit dialog
there's an important design principle
here as well that a message property
should not
override a property the user has
explicitly set in the node's edit dialog
for example in the request node case if
the user has provided url in the edit
dialog
then the node will ignore message.url
this was a deliberate choice to avoid
the cases where a node's behavior
changes unexpectedly
because a user didn't realize a property
happened to still be set on a message in
the flow
the fourth principle is about being
forgiving
nodes should be forgiving in what they
receive and be kind when things go wrong
and a good example is the mqtt node an
empty message payload is just a
collection of bytes
but the node will accept any javascript
type and try to do the right thing with
it
strings numbers booleans all get handled
as we think the user would expect them
to be
passing in an array or object will lead
it to be stringified to json
automatically before it gets published
and i'm sure we've all tripped over the
handling of false like values in
javascript
if a node accepts a true false flag as a
message property
take care to consider how it handles
non-boolean type values
should undefined null zero and empty
string behave
as you think it would the fifth
principle is handling errors with grace
one of the most important things is
ensuring nodes have the proper error
handling to avoid the dreaded uncaught
exception
an uncaught exception will cause the
runtime to shut down
in the immortal words of the node.js
documentation it's simply not safe to
resume normal operation after an unquote
exception
attempting to resume normal after an
unquote exception
can be similar to pulling out the power
cord on upgrading a computer
nine out of ten times nothing happens
but the tenth time the system becomes
corrupted
restarting is the only option we have
the sixth principle is about being
consistent with such a large ecosystem
of nodes available there are a whole
bunch of well-established patterns for
how nodes look and behave
whilst it's good to challenge those
norms it's less good to reinvent the
wheels for sake of it
use the patterns that exist use the
common ui widgets nodered provides
follow the style guide for the help text
it all makes for a better user
experience
ultimately the key is to have empathy
for the user of the node
the goal isn't to outwit them the goal
is to empower them to achieve what
they're trying to do with as good a user
experience as we can manage
and these are all lessons that apply
just as well when designing a regular
node.js module
apis are all about user experience just
because you're exposing your module via
an exported code api rather than the
visual wrappings of a low code
environment
you still want to ensure the user
experience means it's a joy to use
a well-defined api that puts the user
first above the internal implementation
details
will always provide a better end result
get the externals right
first as they are so much harder to
change down the line compared to
internals
now if you maintain an ogs module that
you think would be interesting to expose
in a low
code programming environment i hope i've
given you a bit of a
bit of a flavor some inspiration to try
it out with node red
if you're interested in learning more
then please do get in touch via the
project slack or
discourse forum
i've been nick o'leary from the node-red
project thanks for listening
you